in this comprehensive course on
algorithmic trading you will learn about
three cuttingedge trading strategies to
enhance your financial toolkit latchezar
teaches this course he is an experienced
quantitative researcher and data
scientist in the first module you'll
explore the unsupervised learning
trading strategy utilizing SP 500 stocks
data to master features indicators and
portfolio optimization next you'll
leverage the power of social media with
the Twitter sentiment investing strategy
ranking NASDAQ stocks based on
engagement and evaluating performance
against the QQQ return lastly the
intraday strategy will introduce you to
the gar model combining it with
technical indicators to capture both
daily and intraday signals for potential
lucrative positions hello and welcome to
this free code Camp course on
algorithmic trading machine learning and
Quant strategy with python my name is
Lazar and I'll be your instructor toout
the course and in this course we are
going to develop three big quantitative
projects from start to end and the
course overview would be the following
first we're going to talk about
algorithmic trading Basics then we're
going to talk about machine learning in
trading some obstacles and challenges we
may face while using machine learning in
trading then we are going to develop the
first project which would be an unsup
rised learning trading strategy using
stocks from S&P 500 the next project
would be Twitter sentiment and it would
be using data from NASDAQ 100 stocks and
the third one would be focusing on one
asset it would be an intraday strategy
using a gar model to predict the
volatility it would use simulated data
and after that we are going to have a
quick wrap up and with that we'll finish
the tutorial but before we continue I
would like to mention that this tutorial
should not be ConEd as a financial
advice it is for educational and
entertainment purposes only we are going
to develop some Concepts and come up
with strategies in the end but it's not
a financial advice and you shouldn't
make any decisions based on it as well
for this course I would assume that you
have at least some python knowledge and
understanding because down the road will
deal with some complex problems and if
you're new to python you may get B down
nevertheless you learn some very
interesting Concepts so stay along and
let's get into it okay algorithmic
trading Basics so what is algorithmic
trading it is trading on predefined set
of rules which are combined into a
strategy or a system it is developed by
a programming language and it is run by
the computer it can be used for both
manual and automated trading by manual
what I mean is that you may have a
screener which comes up with a set of
stock stocks you want to trade on a
given day or you may have a algorithmic
strategy which is developed into an
alert system and whenever the conditions
are triggered you get an alert but you
execute it manually on the other hand
you may have a completely automated
complex system which does a lot of
calculation comes up with uh positions
and sizing and then executes the trade
automatically okay so what is the role
of python in algorithmic trading python
is the most popular language used in
Alor trading quantitative finance and
data science and this is mainly due to
the vast amount of libraries that are
developed in python as well the ease of
use of uh python it is mainly used for
data pipelines research back testing
strategies as well it can be used to
automate strategies but python is a slow
language and it can be used to automate
low complexity systems if you have a
really high-end system which is really
complicated and it needs to execute
trades really quickly you would use Java
or C++ for those strategies our gmic
trading is a great career opportunity
it's a huge industry there are a lot of
jobs with hedge funds Banks Prop Shops
and I've just checked the average yearly
base salary for Quant researcher is
around
$173,000 and this is not including the
yearly bonus it is a great career
opportunity and if you're interested
into it the main things you need to know
are python you need to know how to back
test strategies you need to know how to
replicate papers and you need to know
machine learning in trading if you're
interested into it I'll definitely
advise you to go for it okay so let's
move on and talk a little bit about
machine learning in trading and some use
cases of machine learning when we talk
about supervised learning we can use it
for Signal generation through prediction
for example we can come up with buy or
sell signals on a given stock or a given
asset based on predicting the return or
the sign of the return of that asset we
can as well use it in risk management
for example we may use a prediction to
determine the position sizing or the
weight of a given stock in our portfolio
or to predict where exactly should our
stop loss be and with unsup learning we
can use it to extract insights from the
data for example we can discover
patterns relationships or structures
within the data for example clusters and
use it in this way to uh help our
decisions what are some of the
challenges that we may face while trying
to apply machine learning in trading and
the first theoretical challenge we may
face is the so called reflexivity
feedback loop and it is referring to the
phenomenon that if we for example have a
machine learning model that is uh
predicting that a stock is going to go
up each Friday and we can form a
strategy around to profit from that
phenomenon for example we are going to
buy each Thursday and then sell on
Friday to capture that price increase
move if we find this strategy throughout
predictions and start trading it with
time other Market participants as well
are going to find this Market phenomenon
and start to exploiting it as well which
would cause the price to start going up
on Thursday because everybody's buying
now on Thursday instead on Friday and
then this strategy is going to be
Arbitrage away so it's this reflexivity
feedback loop which is making
predictions quite hard what is most hard
while applying machine learning the most
hard thing is to predict returns and
predict prices the next quite hard thing
to do is to predict return signs or the
direction of a given asset is it going
to to go up or down the next thing is to
predict an economic indicator for
example it is quite hard to predict
nonfarm payrolls or weekly jobless
claims and a thing which is not that
hard or quite straightforward is to
predict the volatility of a given asset
furthermore there are some technical
challenges like overfitting a model or
generalization overfitting is that the
model is learned the train data too well
and it fails on the test data and
generalization is that the model is not
performing the same as on the real data
as well we may have nonstationarity in
our training data and regime shifts
which may ruin the the performance of
the model and the last thing is that if
we have a really complicated model or um
neuron Network it is like a black box
and we are not able to interpret it
correctly what is the usual workflow
process in algorithmic trading and
machine learning that would be to
collect and prepare the the data then
develop a hypothesis for a strategy then
you have to code the model and train the
model and then finally back test the
strategy okay guys and some key
takeaways from this course so you learn
high level Concepts in quantitative
Finance as well practical machine
learning in trading you develop a
project from idea to back test final
results however we will not automate or
execute any trades we'll just develop a
strategy this course is all about
developing a strategy from start to end
so you see the workflow and this is just
a purely research project for
educational purposes I repeat it should
not be construed as any Financial advice
whatsoever and with that we can move to
the first project and let's get into it
okay so first project is about
unsupervised machine learning trading
strategy we're going to use data from
S&P 5 500 stocks let's talk a little bit
about unsupervised learning in trading
so it involves machine learning
techniques to analyze financial data and
discover patterns relationships and
structures within this data without
predefined labels or Target variable
unlike supervised learning where the
model is trained to make predictions
unsupervised learning focusing on
extracting insides from the data and
some use cases would be clustering which
we are going to use in the first project
dimensionality reduction anomaly
detection Market regime detection and
portfolio optimization in this project
what we are going to do is first we're
going to download all the prices data
for all S&P 500 stocks then we're going
to calculate different technical
indicators and features for each stock
next we're going to aggregate on a
monthly level and filter only the
top50 most liquid stocks from the S&P
500 for each month next we are going to
calculate PL monthly returns for
different time Horizons to add up to the
features and the next step would be to
download the F French factors and
calculate rolling Factor betas for each
stock as well to add to the feature set
and at this point we'll have enough
features to fit the model and either
make predictions or in our case we're
going to fit a c's clustering algorithm
an unsupervised learning model and we
will use it to group group the stocks
into similar assets into clusters and
from those clusters then we will be able
to for each month select stocks from a
given cluster and we are going to
analyze the Clusters and select a
particular cluster and then for each
month we are going to select those
stocks within this cluster and form
portfolios however these portfolios will
be optimized so the weights of the
stocks within the portfolio we're going
to find them by using the efficient
Frontier Max Sharpie ratio isue
portfolio weights and then we are going
to form the portfolio hold for one month
and rebalance at the end of the month
and you know form another Max sharp
ratio portfolio in the end we'll have
the strategy returns for each day and we
will be able to compare our portfolio
strategy returns to the S&P 500 returns
themselves actually not small limitation
is that we're going to use the most
recent S&P 500 stocks list which means
that there may be a survivor buyers in
this list this is a huge issue actually
in reality you should always uh back
test strategies using survivorship free
bias data what is survivorship bias it
is the condition when a stock which have
actually went out of the S&P 500 because
it was failing is currently not in the
list right so last year for example
there was a stock which was failing and
going down down down so at some point in
December last year they removed it from
S&P 500 and they included a new stock so
if we have made the optimization last
November we could end up with having
this stock into our portfolio and
actually it affecting our portfolio
results but if we use the most recent
S&P 500 symbols list this stock would
not be there so that's survivorship bias
and for the given project we are not
going to deal with this survivorship bu
so the list we are going to work with
has survivorship bus most probably so
yeah that is limitation you need to know
in the second project we are going to
develop a Twitter sentiment based
investing strategy we are going to use
the NASDAQ 100 stocks and Twitter
sentiment data what is sentiment
investing this approach focuses on
analizing how people feel about certain
stocks Industries or the overall Market
it assumes that the public sentiment can
impact stock prices and for example if
many people are positive about a
particular company on Twitter it might
indicate potential for that company
stock to perform well what we are going
to do first we're going to load the
NASDAQ stocks Twitter sentiment data
then we're going to calculate a
quantitative feature of the engagement
ratio in Twitter for each stock after
that we're going to rank all the stocks
cross-sectionally for each month and
create an equal weight portfolio in the
end we're going to compare the return of
this portfolio to the NASDAQ itself the
second strategy is much smaller than the
first strategy there is no machine
learning modeling in this strategy but
the idea here is to show you how
alternative or different data in this
case sentiment data can help us to
create a Quant feature and then create
potential strategy out of it that's the
idea of the second project and the third
project is about an intraday strategy
using a gar model in this one we are
going to focus on a single asset and
we'll be using simulated data actually
we'll have daily data and intraday 5
minute data but what does an intraday
strategy means this approach involves
buying and selling Financial assets
within the same trading day to profit
from the shortterm price movements
intraday Traders usually use technical
analysis real time data and different
risk management techniques to make
decisions and profit from the strategies
what exactly we're going to do in this
project first we are going to load the
simulated daily data and the simulated 5
minute data then we are going to define
a function which would fit in a rolling
window a gar model to predict one day
ahead volatility of the asset after we
have that we'll calculate prediction
premium so we'll predict the volatility
and we'll calculate the prediction
premium and form a daily signal from it
after we have uh calculate that then
we'll merge the daily data with the
intraday data and calculate intraday
technical indicators to form intraday
signal so we will have a daily signal
and then on top an intraday signal so
two signals and after we have that we'll
generate position entry and hold until
the end of the day in the end we're
going to calculate the final strategy
returns and this is it for the third
project the idea is to show you how
predicting volatility Works in uh
intraday strategies and yeah with that
guys we are ready to jump into the first
project so let's get into it okay let's
start with the first project the unup
rised learning trading strategy but
before we continue with the coding guys
the first step would be for you to pause
the video and install all the needed
packages for this project so I prepared
a small list up here with all the
packages we are going to need for the
project so those are pandas numai MP lip
stats models pandas data reader daytime
wi Finance SK learn and buy portfolio op
how you can install the packages you can
do it the following way you can open on
Ana prompt like that right and then just
write pip install and the package name
pip install pandas for example and do
that for each package that's one way
another way to do it is through the
notebook itself you can uh type the
following so pip install and then the
package name so pip install pandas you
do control shift and run the cell and it
will install the package pause the video
take your time install all the packages
and let's continue okay so the first
step would be to download the S&P 500
constituents prices data but before that
we'll have to import all the packages we
use throughout this project I've already
prepared that those are all the packages
we've just installed and now we are
importing into the Jupiter notebook The
Next Step would be to download S&P 500
constituents data to do that we can go
to this link on Wikipedia and up here
you can see that they have a table
containing a S&P 500 component stocks
like the symbol the the name of the
security sector industry date added as
well so quite some data uh so we would
like to load this table into our Jupiter
notebook how we can do that we just call
a pandas read HTML function and let's
see what this would return us okay so
this is returning a list containing two
elements it looks like two data frames
so actually we are interested in the
first frame yeah exactly we will assign
that to an object called S&P 500 and the
next step would be to grab this symbol
column and extract all the symbols in a
list but before that I think we would
have to make a little cleaning on some
of the symbols because I know that one
or two of the symbols contain a DOT and
this would give us an error while we
download data from wi Finance so we have
to actually replace all dots with
Dash and that would do the job next step
would be to you know just grab list with
all the stocks so yeah we can just use
symbol. unique to list we will assign
that to a object called
symbols list and yeah that would be our
symbols list of all S&P 500 stocks as we
talked uh in the beginning this list of
stocks is not Survivor ship bias free so
you need to know that it's uh quite some
of limitation all right so we would like
to download the data up to a few days
ago let's define an object which is end
dat and we'll use
2023 September 27th and the start date
would be
P to date
time and
date it would be exactly 8 years ago so
we can just use the end date and we will
substract eight years out of it how we
can do that we just say pandas to
datetime we'll convert to daytime the
end date and then we'll just substract
pandas date of set and then Supply 365 *
8 all right so now we have the end date
which is yeah 27th of September which is
a string and the start date would be a
time stamp but that's all right because
we are going to download data from y
finance and this function we use from y
Finance download function which takes
tickers as an argument so that would be
our symbols list then start which would
be our start date and end which would be
our end date and now this will download
all the S&P 500 constituents if we run
it yeah it will take some time all right
so we've downloaded all the data for the
S&P 500 stocks we got it up here so the
next step would be to actually yeah
we'll comment out everything and have uh
this object printed out as you can see
up here we have the column and then we
have like a multi index column so first
we have the adjusted close and then we
have the adjusted close for each stock
that's not really convenient to work
with the whole data frame at the moment
we have 2012 rows and 3,8 columns that's
really inefficient how we can overcome
that we would just use the stock method
which now creates a m index the first
level would be the date and then for
each date we have the corresponding 500
stocks adjusted close close high low so
that's much more convenient we have six
columns and almost 1 million rows so we
have to change the datea frame to be
stocked or actually we can move this
method right up here after the download
directly and yeah now we have our data
frame stacked Next Step would be I would
always when I have a multi-index I would
always want to have labels on both of
the index levels so we'll say index.
names and we'll assign the new name so
date and thicker that will be our new
multi-index names as you see they change
step here next step would be to fix the
columns a little bit I I would like to
fix the column names to be not as titles
but with a lower letters so that would
be DF do columns DF do columns do string
lower and that's pretty much it with the
downloading and fixing data a little bit
before we move to the next step which
would be to start calculating technical
indicators and features of all those
53 stocks okay so in the second step we
can start calculating the features and
Technical indicators for each stock we
are going to calculate the garm class
volatility RSI Ballinger bands ATR macd
and dollar volume for each stock let's
first start with the garm class
volatility what is garm class volatility
it is volatility measure usually used in
Forex Trading but it works for stocks as
well it is approximation to measure the
intraday volatility of a given asset and
that is the formula right here so what
do we do we Define a new column called
garmon class V and it would be the
following so log from the high minus log
from the low so that would be yeah from
the low this whole thing is squared and
then it is divided by two then from this
we substract 2 * log 2us one multiplied
by subtraction of log from the adjusted
close yeah
minus log from the
open again the hold think is squared and
we just close another bracket and that
should be it that should be the gar
class volatility yes so we now have
calculated the gar class volatility for
each stock it is calculated on a given
role we don't need to do any fancy
calculations for this one the next one
is RSI so how do we calculate the RSI on
each stock what we're going to do we are
going to group Buy on the thicker level
so level one the multi- index has level
zero and level one which is the thicker
level zero is the date level one is the
thicker so we grew by on level one then
we are selecting the column which would
be adjusted close and apply the
transform method and within the
transform method we just apply a Lambda
function which would be so now we have
grouped grouped by on each thicker and
what do we want to do we want to
calculate the RSI to calculate the RSI
we are going to use the pandascore TA
package which is the package to
calculate pretty much all of the needed
technical indicator so we use the
pandascore TA package and from the
pandascore we use the RSI function the
side function we have to supply the
close price which would be X and the
length would be 20 and yeah if we do
that you see now we have the
RSI for each stock how we can double
check our work we select
apple and then RSI and then we'll plot
it and yeah as you can see the r side
goes up and down up and down so we have
worked correctly the next indicator we
would like to calculate is Ballinger
bands and actually we would want to have
the lower band the middle band and the
upper band but there is one
specification for each indicator from
now on we would like to normalize and
scale the indicator itself so for the
Binger BNS will will supply the log from
the close price first the function we
are going to use is from Panda CA B
bands and it is taking the clothes just
for presentational purposes we Supply a
upper adjusted close and the length will
be 20 when you run this function it
returns five columns so the first one is
the lower band the second one is the
middle band and the third one is the
upper band we have to take this into
account and what we are going to do is
pretty much you know Define a new column
BBL low Ballinger band low and we use
the the same idea as for the RSI we are
going to group by each thicker select
the adjusted close column and then we
use the transform method Lambda function
and in the Lambda function we say pandas
ta B bands close would be equal to X
actually it will be equal to log of x so
MP log 1 p and then the length would be
again 20 when we run that it will return
those five columns what we actually want
to do is assign to B below the First
Column which we know is the B the lower
Ballinger band we can say iock all the
rows and the First Column we can repeat
the same operation for the midband and
for the upper band okay but this happens
when I forget something and I think I
have forgot I forgot the second curly
bracket to close the curly brackets
let's see what this would return yeah
guys after you return and calculate
something you can just select all the
the code you've used and comment it out
okay we forgot to change the names that
would be BB mid and first index that
would be BB High the second index okay
let's run that again and see what we get
awesome now we have the lower bager Bond
Middle Ballinger Bond and upper
Ballinger Bond and we have the data
scaled and normalized next step is to
calculate the ATR for each stock however
the ATR function needs three inputs so
three columns not only one column and
when we use transform method in pandas
it is actually working when you select
only one column it would not work if you
have three columns as an input so we
would have to use another approach more
specifically that would be a group by
apply and to do that we need to Define
our own custom function to calculate the
ATR we can uh double check what the ATR
function from pandas ta requires as
input and it is the high so we have to
supply the high then we have to supply
the low and the close price furthermore
we can supply the length for example 14
and yeah it will mess mess up with the
data if we run it like that because we
have to select the data for a given
stock but yeah you see that it requires
three columns so here we we going to
define a function called compute ATR it
will take stock data and here we will
just calculate at which would be pandas
ta. high would be stock data
High the low then we have we need a
close the length would be 14 all right
and a little detail we are going to add
of here is we are going to normalize the
data while we calculate it so that would
be ATR do substract first first we are
going to the mean and then we are going
to divide it by the standard deviation
so ATR do standard deviation and yeah
that will be our ATR indicator function
now we can just say ATR create a new
column called ATR and group by level one
again so we are applying that for each
stock however up here when we use the
group by apply we need to add an
additional argument to the group bio
which is group key is equal to false
because if we don't do that it will
double the the date column so it will
return another date colum and we have a
triple multi-index with two date columns
we don't want that so we just say group
Cas equals to false and then apply this
function and this will now calculate the
ATR index normalized for each stock the
next indicator we are going to calculate
is the macd indicator and for the macd
we're going to follow the same logic as
as for the ATR indicator we're going to
Define our own custom function to
compute the macd so it will be called
compute macd it will take the close
price and up here we are going to say
magd is equals to pandas ta. magd close
equal to close length is 20 and then we
would like to get the First Column which
would be returned however in the end as
well we are going to normalize the dat
we're going to the meain the series and
then we're going to divide by the
standard deviation why do we do that
right away we're normalizing the data
because we are going to use it into a
machine learning model we are going to
Cluster the data we want to do that
straight away and don't think about it
later in the future so here we are going
to do again group buy level one each
scker on each stock group Keys equal to
false and then apply compute Mark D this
would calculate calate the mag the
indicator for each stock all right we
have an error why do we have this error
that's quite
strange oh okay I'm sorry I'm sorry I
forgot to add the adjusted close column
up here and this is driving the eror all
right so we will return back I lock in
the first corn that should be guys all
right yeah now we have the macd as well
calculated and normalized as you can see
we have the data looks pretty good so
far the only indicator we are not going
to normalize is the RSI and there is a
particular reason for that but you uh
understand more about it when we come to
the clustering part all the other
indicators we are going to normalize and
the final one is the dollar volume so
we're going to create a new column
dollar volume which would be equal to
the adjusted close multiplied by the
volume however we may want to actually
divide that by 1 million for each stock
because we know that millions of shares
are traded each day and this would make
sense as you can see now the data looks
much better for the dollar volume right
and that's pretty much it with uh
calculating the first batch of features
our technical indicators now we have a
really beautiful data frame for each day
we have all the 500 stocks we have the
close price low open volume garment
class volatility RSI Ballinger band ATR
macd and the dollar volume for each
stock and we are now ready to move to
the next and the third step in the third
step what we want to do is to aggregate
on a monthly level the data and filter
the top 150 most liquid stocks for each
month why do we do that we do that to
reduce training time for any potential
machine learning model and experiment
with features and strategies what is my
idea here I would like to aggregate all
the indicators so those five I would
like to take the end value the end of
the last value for the month as well the
same for the adjusted close price and
for the dollar volume I would like to
get the average dollar volume for the
whole month for each stock we can start
actually what we can do first is uh take
the data frame un stock the thicker
level so we'll unstack thicker and then
we're going to select the dollar volume
column and if we run that we have the
dollar volume for each day for each
stock now right and what we can do is
just resample to monthly and take the
mean this should resample to monthly now
as you can see we have monthly index end
of each month and we have the average
dollar volume for the month what we can
do now is just stack it back into a MTI
index like that and we can say two frame
to make it uh a data frame with one
column two frame dollar volume beautiful
that would be the first step however for
the indicators what we can do is we can
follow the same logic but we need to
select the exact columns actually we may
create a list of columns so last call
and this would be our list of columns
for which we want to do the same
operation however we would use the last
method up here instead of mean and those
columns would be C for C in DF do
columns.
unique and yeah the first element C for
C in do in DF columns. unique if C is
not in the following columns list so if
the column is not dollar volume it is
not volume it is not open it is not high
low or close pretty much we want to do
that only for the technical indicators
columns so for those columns we don't
want to use these columns for our
aggregation we want just the Fe we are
creating the features data frame in the
end right we would use the dollar volume
to filter out the most liquid stocks the
dollar volume would not be featured in
our model as well NE neither the volume
or open low high close after we have
defined the last columns uh we can
actually proceed with the next
aggregation we have done the dollar
volume aggregation the next one would be
for DF last C we are going to
unstack actually we are going to un
stack before that so we are going to
unstack we're going to unstack and
select those columns and then resample
to monthly and then just use the last
volume like that and again we're going
to stack backwards into a multi-index
voila and now what we can do is concut
those two together we can say the
following pandas cona and that would be
axis axis
one and boom we have the dollar volume
the average dollar volume and the last
value for adjusted close ATR and other
technical indicators for each month now
we have aggregated the data to monthly
level for the features we would need
actually what we can uh what we can add
up here is a small drop and that looks
much more beautiful
and we can call that
data
and let's visualize what we have yeah
that's our data all right and that's the
first step with the aggregating to a
monthly level The Next Step would be to
calculate the fiveyear rolling average
dollar volume for each stock and then
you use this uh aggregated dollar volume
to filter out only the top
150 most liquid stocks for each month
how do we approach that first we can
start by selecting the dollar volume
like that so what we can do select the
dollar volume and stack the thicker
level and now we can use a rolling
function with a window of 5 * 12 so 5
years and then we can calculate the mean
as you can see now we have the rolling
average
mean for each stock rolling average
5year dollar volume for each stock and
again we can just stack backwards and
that's pretty much our dollar volume
column what we can do now is we can
assign it to the dollar volume column
update to The fiveyear Rolling average
for each stock awesome after we have
that the next step is to calculate the
dollar volume rank cross section
for each month how do we do that we can
say data Group by level zero or date so
we can Group by on date for each month
we're going to select the dollar volume
and just rank ascending equal to false
let's see what this would give
us
ascending and now as you can see we have
all the stocks ranked by Dollar volume
and the the ones the the guys who have
the smallest dollar volume have the the
highest rank so we want the top
150 and from here we can pretty much
very easily select the stocks which are
below 150 for each month and those would
be the top50 most liquid stocks for each
month after we have selected them we can
just drop the two columns we can drop
the dollar volume and the dollar volume
rank because we are not going to need
them anymore access equals to one and
that's pretty much it for our we can
assign that to
data and that's pretty much it with our
third step where now we have aggregated
monthly data for all the features we
would need plus the adjusted close price
and we can move move on with the next
step the fourth step and that would be
calculating monthly returns for
different time Horizons and add them as
additional features to the ones we
already have here okay so let's move to
that step I'll just cut those sales in
the middle all right why do we want to
calculate the monthly returns for
different time Horizons and uh add them
to the feature set because we may want
to capture time series dynamics that
reflect for example the momentum
patterns for each stock to do that we
can just use the pandas data frame
method uh percent underscore change and
Supply the different logs my Approach
would be to use logs for 1 month two
months 3 months 6 months 9 months and 12
months that's uh like six different uh
LS to really capture the momentum
patterns how do we approach that let's
first start by for example selecting the
Apple stock I just want to make a little
example so we'll select the Apple stock
and let's see what we have here all
right now we would like to calculate the
returns for the following lcks for one
month two months 3 months 6 months 9
months and 12 months right as well we
may want to have an outlier cut off
because we are dealing with a lot of
stocks there will definitely be outlier
values in the returns of those stocks
what do we want to do we want to with
them by clipping them what clipping does
is that for all values which are above
the outlier threshold they will just be
assigned the threshold of that percent
up the cut off value we may want to have
it as a 0.05 which means the
99.5 percenti that would be our outlier
cut off and now what we do is just for
each log so for log in logs for each log
we are going to create a column which
would be the return for the given log
for the given log month right that would
be the column and then we grab the
adjusted close then we just do percent
change Lo so for each lck we'll
calculate the following column which
would calculate the given return and
then we want to deal with the outliers
right so that would be pipe Lambda so
far we have the adjusted close and then
we calculate the return for the given L
and then we input that into the pipe
Lambda X we can clip now we clip the
return and we can clip the lower band
the lower cut off we'll use x
quantile and we supply for the lower cut
off just outl cut off and for the upper
one we Supply x quantile one minus
outline cut off then we add one to the
power of 1 / by the log and we substract
one in the end and that should be it
guys now we can see that for our Apple
stock which is G right we have the one
month return two months return 3 months
6 months 9 months 12 months Etc how we
can extend that we just use the same
approach we use for the at and the macd
indicators we will create our own custom
function and then we you just use the
group by apply methodology for the bound
data frame so calculate returns it takes
DF for example and just move that a
little bit return DF in the end however
up here we have to change that to DF
this one to DF as well and that's pretty
much it our function and now we can say
the following data equals to data. group
by level one because we Group by on the
thicker level so we can say uh Group by
ticker or level one let's say level one
and then we want Group keys to be false
so we don't have two uh date indexes
assigned to the new date frame so Group
keys false then apply we apply the
calculator T function and in the end we
may want to drop the na values and yeah
this would take some time and yeah
that's pretty much it I mean now we have
added the return features as well which
we would use to capture momentum
patterns for each stock and that's
pretty much it with the fourth step the
calculating the monthly returns for
different on Horizons and we can move to
the next step which is really
interesting actually adding even more
features to our data set that would be
to download the F French factors and we
are going to calculate the rolling
Factor better for each stock in our data
all right let's move to it okay so in
this step we're going to download the
farm French factors data and calculate
the rolling Factor betas for each stock
in our current data set so we want to
introduce the F French data to estimate
the exposure of our assets to commonly
known risk factors and we're going to do
that using a regression rolling OS model
the five round French factors namely
Market risk size value profitability and
invest M have been shown to empirically
explain asset returns in the past and
are commonly used in the asset
management industry to assess the risk
return profile of different portfolios
so it kind of makes sense to include
them in our current feature data set how
we can do that we can use the pandas
data reader package we which we imported
as web we can use this package to
download the F French Factor models but
before that we may want to to take a
look at the we might want to take a look
at the data so we can Google it Farm
French factors and up here you can find
the canid French data Library just click
on it and this is the part we are
interested in in FAL French 5 research
factors 2 * three so those five factors
that's the data we are interested in if
you scroll down a little bit you can
find the daily data right here you can
download it as txt or CSV file as well
you can check the details they have
monthly returns and annual returns we
are interested in the monthly returns as
our data is already on a monthly level
right so what we can do is uh we can say
the following web. data reader data
reader and up here we have to supply the
name of the exact Factor so the exact
file so I have prepared it already
that's the name then we say F French
then the start date we want 2010 this is
returning a dictionary with two keys the
first one is the monthly factors and the
second one is the yearly factors that's
awesome so we want the monthly factors
only and that's the data we have 164 uh
months up to August 2023 that's pretty
good however I think we don't even
though the risk-free return is pretty
solid right now it is out of the scope
of this tutorial so we'll just drop it
we say drop RF AIS equal to one and and
that's perfect we can call this uh
assign it to factor
data and
yeah that's our Factor data let's check
the index the index is uh monthly yeah
all right so I think we have to fix the
index as well so we can call of pandas
to daytime and Supply the index let's
see if this would
work okay we have to use to time stamp
all right
okay so now we have fixed the index as
well as you can see now it's it has the
year the month and the beginning of
month date however our data is end of
month that's one thing we have to fix
another one is that I see that the
factors are in
percentages so we would have to divide
them by 100 how we can fix that we can
just say resum P to monthly and get the
last
value which would fix immediately the
issue yeah with the beginning of mandate
next we can say divide by 100 and that's
perfect we just assign
that to factor
data comment it out yeah next we want to
fix the name of the index to be just
date
and the next step would be to join with
the pretty much join with the one month
return why would we want to do that
because at the beginning of each month
we have the factors and then we have the
return of each stock at the end of the
same month so now we have fixed the date
of the factors we can just join with the
end of month return and then we can can
regress them and take the beta right if
the factor is predictive we have it at
the beginning of the month and we will
regress it with the return of the end of
the month so we'll get the the the beta
how we can do that factor data join and
then from our
data we can select the one return column
let's see what this would give is that's
perfect now we can sort the
index
and
just assign to factor data what we may
want to do here is to double check our
work we can select two
stocks for example
apple and let's say
Microsoft and we can double check the
return yeah the return is different but
the factors stay the same looks like we'
worked
correctly and we are ready to move to
the next step in this step we are going
to filter out stocks that have less than
10 month data why are we doing that
because we are going to use rolling
window for the regression of around 2
years 24 months and stocks that don't
have enough data would actually break
our function so we have to remove them
from the data set how we can do that we
can say Factor
data. groupby level one and then just
call the size method and now we can see
how many months of data we have for each
stock okay guys and I just realized that
we have made a small mistake somewhere
because we have only 23 months of data
for each stock and I had to go back
through the code and actually f figure
out that on this step uh this part was
missing which was the data dolog
selecting all the rows and then the
dollar volume column you can just rerun
this sale and you can see that here our
our first month is in 205 November and
after that it was 2020 so when you add
the dot loog and selecting the all the
rows and the dollar volume column you
get the fixed data then we can rerun as
you can see up here it's 2021 the first
date if we run it it should be much
backwards in the past yeah so
2017 31st of October and we have to do
that again for the factor data two and
if we run now yeah now we have 71 months
right and the idea here is uh that we
remove all the stocks that have less
than 10 months of data how do we do that
we can just assign that to
observations and then we can save valid
stocks that would be
observations that would be all the
stocks that have more than 10 months of
data observations yeah those are our
valid stocks and now we can just use
that as a filter so Factor data
would be
Factor
data again Factor data. index do get
level
values we get the thicker values maybe I
can show you what this is returning this
is returning uh yeah an object with all
the the stocks we have in the thicker
index part of our M index and then we
can just say is in the valid stock
stocks and this would filter out pretty
much
everything we have to add this
part
okay okay so I
think oh yeah
I missed this part should
be all stock
index those are the stocks we are going
to remove so if we take that
out yes so now as you can see we hit
before we hit 10,21 rows now we have
10,250 we've removed around 51 rows and
yeah with this step we are now ready to
calculate the rolling Factor betas we
would like to do that simultaneously for
all the stocks in our Factor data we can
just use the same methodology with Group
by and apply a function that would be
Factor
data. Group by and then we're grouping
by level one by ticker Group keys should
be false
and we can put that into brackets
so we can continue on the next row so
apply Lambda X and now we want to
use the rolling
regression actually we may want to
explore the rolling
regression rolling ORS
python it takes the endog and exog all
right we here Supply endog and exog so
the endog would be our return column
right so
X return one month and our xog would be
everything else what we can do here is
say x do
drop the return one month column and
this would return all the other this
would give all the other columns without
the return and actually we can add a
constant here on the spot so we add a
constant and I think the next one we
have to supply the window we decided the
window to be 2 years right so that would
be 24 right 24 months and there is
another mean
observation the minimum number of
observation required to estimate the
model we have to supply this one as well
this one is a little bit more tricky we
have to supply here to have at least the
total number of columns plus one so that
would be Lan x. columns plus one and
this should be our model now we have to
say fit and then
params and then we can drop the we can
drop the constant because it will return
constant as we added a constant up here
right and I think this should pretty
much work except that maybe sometimes we
would not have exactly 24 months of
observations but we still may want to
run the regression so what we can do is
use as a window the value which is
smaller than two Val so it either 24
months or we can use the number of rows
we have in the for the given stock right
and we know that we have stocks with
more than 10 months of data so if one of
the stocks have like 15 months of data
you just use the 15 months as a window
instead of 24 and yeah I think that
should pretty much be it
right okay series object doesn't have
fit
why right
maybe okay so that's pretty
much that's pretty much uh our rolling
Factor betas we have calculated them now
we can assign them to
betas
and that's our rolling Factor BS guys in
The Next Step what we want to do is to
join them to our current features and
with that we have our Full Features data
set but before we join them we have to
think about a little bit now we have the
rolling Factor betas where we used the
factor at the beginning of the month and
the return at the end of the month so
this beta we would actually know at the
next month right at the end of the month
we go we'll be able to run the
regressions and have the betas but we'll
have them in the next month so we cannot
just blindly join them to the features
data we have so far what we have to do
is to shift them
with one month forward before we join
them to the data because these values we
would have no not known in the same
month we would know uh we would know the
mon the the rolling Factor better for
example for the end of October we would
know them in November what we have to do
is we have to shift with one month
forward on the ticker level so for each
ticker not like the whole data frame if
we just say
betas do shift it will run it will shift
with one row downwards and for example
the value of Verizon will come up up
here right just see that so Verizon is
0.3 if we apply
shift it's now here so that's obviously
not correct so what we have to do is we
have to first group
by and we can do that group by thicker
and then we can
shift that would now uh do it correctly
we can grab that and Supply it
here
and data will be equal to
this and the next step that we want is
to impute the missing values of each
factor with the average for that factor
beta how we we can do that we can say
first we can create a a list with the
factor columns factors would
be just those five
columns we can say data. log all the
rows factors
we'll just select all the factors and
all the rows and then we can say the
following data. Group by ticker for each
ticker we'll select the factors again
and then we'll just apply a Lambda
function Lambda X where we will F all
the missing values with the mean of this
Factor but I think because we are doing
grp Group by apply we have to add the
group
keys to be
false and
now we should have fixed our missing
vales
issue voila so now we don't have any
missing Valu so all all the nas are
imputed by the average for this factor
and yeah now we can just say drop a if
there are
any and we can say data. info to see our
final
result
and that is now beautiful guys this is
our features data set however I see a
column we don't need here which is the
adjusted close we just have to drop it
data is equal to data drop adjusted
close axis equal to
one and
and this is our features data set guys
so we have 18 features at this moment we
are now ready to apply machine learning
models from here on what we have to
decide usually is for each new month we
have to form a portfolio with some of
the stocks from our uh data set so as we
know we have for each month we have the
top 150 most liquid stocks and now now
at the end of each month we have to
decide the stocks we want to have in our
portfolio for the next month that's
where we can use a machine learning
model first we can use a machine
learning model to predict which stocks
to include in the portfolio as well if
we have a long short portfolio we have
we can predict which stocks to be long
and which stocks to be short but in this
course we are just focusing on Long Port
foros so we can use a machine learning
model to predict which stocks as well we
can use machine learning model to
predict the magnitude of the position in
each stock so what is the weight in the
portfolio and the other way is to use a
machine learning model in our case a
nonsupervised model to decide which
stocks to use in the portfolio based on
grouping that's why we are going to use
a clustering algorithm a KES clustering
to keep things simple because from this
point on things can get really
complicated but yeah that's so far was
the preparation to get the data to fit
into a machine learning model guys and
yeah I'm really excited in the next step
we are going to fit a c's clustering
algorithm and split the data in in a few
clusters each stock will be assigned a
cluster and then we'll uh be able to
analyze the Clusters and decide what we
do further let's move to this step okay
so in this step we're going to fit the C
clustering algorithm for each month and
split the stock stocks into four
different groups based on their features
y four I've already did a a little work
beforehand and I've estimated that the
optimal number of clusters roughly on
average for each month is around four so
we'll use four clusters for each month
uh from now on the specifications about
the K's clustering algorithm is that it
uh it may assign the centroids of the
Clusters around randomly and then it
assigns a given point to the cluster
based on the distance from the centrate
to that point to uh help you understand
a little bit more so this is an example
with the same data but different number
of clusters specified when fitting the
model so in the first one we have two
clusters as you can see really well
defined three four and five whenever we
initialize the model we have to specify
how many clusters we want the data to be
grouped in and the algorithm would go in
assign random points and then the
closest points to the Cent read so
Random Cent the closest point to the
Cent would be assigned to that cluster
and until uh that will be repeated until
all points have an assigned cluster how
do we start here let's first import the
C's class from
sklearn do cluster we are going to
import K
means and now what we want to do right
is fit uh K means model for each month
and assign a cluster to each stock so
get the label we can do that at once
using the group by apply logic we've
already used for ATR and macd we can
define a function which should be get
clusters to take data or DF it's up to
you and then we'll create a new column
called
cluster and here
we'll fit the CES model so the CES class
takes first argument number of clusters
that would be four as we already
know I've done my research
beforehand and then we'll use the random
State argument to be zero this would
ensure it works like random seed this
would sure that we have the same results
through different calls and there is
another really important argument here
they need this is the initialization
method of the centroids actually here
for now we'll use a random
initialization but we can actually
Supply here the initial Central points
for the Clusters and we may use that in
the future so let's see the first result
we fit the model follow to the data
frame and then we'll get the labels we
will return the labels and we will
assign them to the cluster column and we
just return the data frame in the end
and now we
can say the following data drop na we
will ensure that we don't have any na in
the data Group by level one or date and
then Group keys equals to false because
we do group by apply
and then apply get
clusters this will take some time but it
will now go through each month and fit
the K clustering algor with four
clusters and assign the given cluster to
each stock let's wait for this to run
okay so the clustering is finished let's
take a look at the results now we have
the cluster column and in it we have the
assigned values from 0 to three so four
clusters 0 1 2 three for each stock and
that is done every month now the next
step would be to visualize actually our
clustering job which is pretty hard when
we use more than two features and in our
case we have 18 but that's why we didn't
apply we didn't apply normalization to
the RSI because now we can use it to
visualize the clustering job in Better
Way all right so I've already wrote down
a small function for that up
here this is a plot function uh we just
select the stocks for the first the
second the third and the fourth cluster
and then we just visualize them with a
with a scatter plot and my idea here is
to do that for each month so we can use
this function it will select for the
scattering it will select the first
column which is the 8 R and the seventh
column which is the
RSI and let's do that now p. style. use
we use the ggplot style always and now
for I in data. index get level
values and we'll get all all the months
so
unique to
list for each month we are going to
select pretty much this month right so
data. x uh Xs and then I level
zero so we are going to select the month
and we're going to
use this function so we for each month
we will just plot the
Clusters
however we may want
to
add the month to the title so we can do
that in the following way
date all let's run this thing
and check our clustering job all right
guys so now for each month we have uh
our clustering job so those are all the
stocks and on the Y label we have the
RSI values and here we have the ATR
values and those are our clusters as you
can see they're pretty well defined
throughout the different
months and if you go through it the
first observation is that actually the
clustering is working in such a way that
all the stocks which are around 60 to 70
RSI are in one cluster then you have the
two middle two midles from 50 to 60 and
from 50 to 40 and then you have the down
cluster here around 35 and what we can
see is that this assumption or this
observation holds throughout each month
of clustering however the problem is
that for example in this month cluster
zero is around 30 35 RSI cluster one is
around 40 to 50 right but then uh this
is the same for the next month but at
some point cluster zero is around 50 and
cluster one is around 60 because the
Cent RS are random our clustering gets
random and my idea for the strategy
we're going to apply is that we would
like to follow stocks momentum by stocks
momentum I would use the RSI as an as
the main indicator right the stocks
which are around 70
RSI are in an upward momentum and I
would like our strategy to invest every
month in the stocks that have have the
highest upward momentum throughout the
previous month for that job I would like
to focus on the stocks that are
clustered around RSI of 65 to
7075 but using the random initialization
of the Clusters would not work and as we
can see so what we have to do now is to
help a little bit the CIS clustering Alm
by
supplying the initial centroids but how
we can do that let's check out the K's
documentation okay so that's the init
argument so the default is C++ we used
random but if an array is passed it
should be of shape so this shape and
clusters and features and gives the
initial centers of the Cent that's
exactly what we want to do and we
want the initial centers to be based on
our RSI indicator pretty much what we
want is that all the stocks which are
around 70 RSI to be for each month to be
in the same cluster then 55 the same
cluster then 45 the same cluster and 30
the same cluster obviously that would be
a little bit better than just deciding
those thresholds ourselves for example
if you want to select all the stocks
above 70 every month we'll have a
different result than using this
clustering algorithm to do the
clustering around 70 for US based on all
the features we have in the data set now
we have to supply to the clustering
algorithm
this this array in in this shape with
the initial
centers okay so let's do that so first
we would like to have the target RSI
values and that would be a list with the
first Target RSI value would be 30 45 55
and 70 then our initial
centroids would be n Pi zeros and we
were we are going to use the target Val
so the length to the Target
values which is
four and then the number of features
right
four and
18 because we know that we have 18
columns right 18 features and that would
be our initial sent rats however let's
run
that yeah I think I forgot that part
yeah so that's our array however up here
we have to supply the sent R what we
were going to do is the following all
rows and this column as we know that the
sixth the the seventh column so the
sixth index the seventh column is our
RSI column in the features data set
we're going to
just change that to the RS Target RSI
values and we'll get the following here
we have the initial sent RS and that's
our array we're going to use for the
clustering job we have to supply it here
but before that we would have to first
drop the cluster colum and rerun the
whole clustering so data is equal to
data
drop this will now drop the cluster
column and rerun the the clustering and
assign the centroids as we have supplied
this will ensure that throughout each
month we'll have the same cluster label
assigned to the stocks corresponding to
the the same cluster as you can see
again in the first month in October we
have assigned cluster two to all stocks
with RSI around 70 in the next month
it's cluster one we want that to be
always cluster
two that's why we are doing it okay
let's run it we have to wait again for
the model to fit okay and it's
done we have fit now the model with our
initial
centroids and we can just now rerun the
visualization let's do that now okay so
now cluster three is assigned for stocks
uh with our around
70 and this is consistent for each month
it's again cluster three cluster three
cluster three cluster three and now we
can use that down the road to select
every month the stocks which are for
example in cluster three to form our
portfolio site and we know that cluster
3 is corresponding to stocks that have
had a good momentum through the previous
month with that we are ready to move to
the next step which is at the beginning
of each new month we're going to select
the stocks we want to invest in for the
given for that
month okay guys so we are at the most
exciting part now we are going to select
stocks based on our clustering and then
we are going to form a portfolio using
an efficient Frontier optimized Max
Sharpie weights for those those stocks
we want to choose a cluster based on our
hypothesis and as we talked earlier my
hypothesis here is that stocks which had
an RSI around 70 are having a good
momentum and my idea is that this
momentum should keep outperforming in
the next month and for this job I've
analyzed all the Clusters throughout the
months and I saw that cluster 3 is
always stocks around 70 R side and in
this case I would like to select those
stocks for every month for my portfolio
how do I do that we just select stocks
corresponding to Cluster I'm sorry to
Cluster
three for each month okay so here we can
call that
filtered data
frame and
assign
that okay so now after we have our
filter data frame now the first step is
to actually get so at the end of October
right on 31st of October we had those
stocks that's our list of stocks which
we would like to use to invest in
November my idea here is to create a
dictionary with the first day of the
next month and all the stocks for the
for the next month in a list to do that
we have to do the following so filter DF
we first reset the index we reset
actually only the first
[Music]
level
okay
all right so we've done that and now now
we can do the following we can just use
the
index and add one date to it so pandas
date of set one which would
move each index with one day in the
future as we know all the indexes are
the last day of the month so we'll have
the beginning of the next
month
like this and the next step would be to
do the following so we we can reset the
index and
then we can set the index again to be a
multi-index so we have date and
thicker let's see all right perfect if
that doesn't work to you you can do
unstuck and then stuck
but it's not necessary at the moment we
do this step and then the next step
would be to create the dates object so
dates would be index. get level
values
we get all the
months and then what we have to do is to
create this dictionary which is having a
key the date so the beginning of the new
month and value would be a list of all
the stocks for that month we can call
that fixed
dates it would be a dictionary and then
for D in
dates we do the
following fix
dates do
D here we'll fix it to be string have
time in our format year
month day
and this would be equal to filtered data
frame pretty much we will
select each month right we select each
month and then we get the index after we
select the month the index will be the
tickers and then we call it to
list and that's pretty much it this
should give
us
this should create for us this
dictionary and voila we have it so now
we have the first day of the next month
right and the stocks list we the stocks
we want to invest for the next month
into a list and actually we can now
really easily use that to create our
portfolios and with that we are ready
for this step so the next step is to
Define find the portfolio optimization
function we're going to use the
portfolio opt package and the efficient
Frontier to have on a portfolio which
maximizes the Sharpie ratio so okay
let's move to define the portfolio
optimization function we'll use to do
that first we will import from pfolio op
package a few different classes so from
P PF
op do effici efficient
Frontier we import the efficient
Frontier class
then
from ppf opt we import risk
models and again
from ppf op we will
import the
expected returns object okay so now what
do we want to do so at the beginning of
each month we have the list of stocks we
are going to invest and those stocks we
have to assign weights to them we have
to find those weights we are going to
use this package to optimize and find
those weights for every month we'll
Define this
optimize weights function which will
take two argument prices actually one
argument for now and and uh we'll add
another one in the later on so first
we'll the the function will take only
the the prices of all the stocks we want
the weights to be optimized for first we
have to calculate the returns of those
stocks so we will use the expected
returns from expected returns we use a
method called mean
historical return which take an argument
price PR and we will supply the prices
as well it takes an argument
frequency and that would be 252 days so
one year of trading data then we have to
calculate the co variance and this time
we use the risk models so from risk
models sample Co
variance again we have to supply the
prices and the
frequency again one year of data after
we have calculated the returns and the
co variance we can now initialize our
efficient Frontier object efficient
Frontier and now we can take a look by
portfolio op
efficient from here let's read the
docs okay but that's the
general we want the mean variance
optimization okay so the efficient
Frontier takes the following argents so
expected Returns the covariance Matrix
weight bounce and then the
so all right the expected
returns maybe we can just c
those
the expected returns would be our just
calculated Returns the C coverance
Matrix would
be C and we will keep this weight bounce
for now I will show you
why and we use the S CS
store and after we have that we can just
calculate the weights weights would be
from efficient Frontier we will use the
max Sharpie
method that should give us the weights
and then in the end we can get the clean
weights which will be round the weights
and Clips near zeros so we we want the
the clean weights we will just return
ef. clean weights and that this
our portfolio optimization function so
obviously we have to supply the onee
prices to this function and it will
calculate the returns of those stocks so
we have a data frame with one year
prices of all the stocks for a given
month this function will calculate the
returns it will calculate the co
variance then it will fit the efficient
Frontier optimization and come up with
the optimized Max Sharpie ratio weights
and return the weights however there is
a small specification and that is the
weight bounce pretty much this is the
bounce for a single stock what can be
the constraint for weight of a given
stock at the moment it is from zero to
one so after the optimization we may
have some stocks with zero weight and we
may have a single stock with 100% weight
obviously we don't want that so we will
come back and fix it but yeah that's uh
pretty much our function for
diversification
purposes we would like to actually have
a maximum weight of 10%
of our portfolio in a single stock so we
can already assign that to be
0.1 but for the lower bound we may use a
more Dynamic metric so we'll create a
argument here lower
bound which would be equal to zero
but for example for the lower bound when
we do the optimization we may use half
the weight of an equally weighted
portfol for example for a given month we
have
20 stocks an equally weighted portfolio
would have 5% in each stock so we may
assign half of that weight let's say
with 20 stocks we may have um the
smallest weight to be 2.5% half of equal
weight and the maximum to be
10% and with this we will ensure that we
have a diversified and well balance
portfolio and yeah guys with that we're
ready for the next step and in The Next
Step we're going to download fresh daily
prices of all the stocks that may end up
in our portfolios as we know the first
portfolio we are going to form at 1st of
November
2017 and from our optimized weights
function we know that we need at least
one year of data prior to the
optimization so the starting date of our
uh of the download should be 2016 1st of
November at least and
to download the prices we can just use
wi Finance package the first step would
be to create the stocks list actually we
can go back and use the data object that
would be the 150 most liquid stocks
because any one of them may end up in
our portfolio we want the data for them
so data. index. get level
values get level
values that will be thicker right or
thicker values
unique and then to list so we have the
stocks list and then we can create the
new data frame uh we can yeah the new
data frame we download from y
finance thers will be our stocks and now
the start date yeah as we know the first
date we want at least one year before
that so we can actually to make things
Dynamic we can use the data do
index
get level values but here we we'll get
the the the months then we take the
first value so the first month that
would
be October
2017 but we can just
say minus Panda's date of set and then
months equal to one so minus one month
this would return us exactly end
of September 2016
actually I went to 2017 okay so we want
12 months we want one whole year I'm
sorry my bad
guys that's exactly what we want so that
would be our start date and our end date
would be pretty
much the same however that would be the
final value from our unique month index
of the day date
object and that's pretty much it this
will download the data we need for our
optimization and after this is
downloaded we are ready for the next
step where the most interesting part is
coming we are going to Loop over the
fixed dates dictionary and for each new
month we're going to get the stocks
optimize the weights calculate the daily
portfolio return and then uh calculate
the whole time period portfolio return
by rebalancing and optimizing every new
month the download is done and we're
ready to move to the next
step first we are going to calculate the
returns the daily returns for each stock
from the fresh new data we just
downloaded and then again we're going to
Loop over each month select the stocks
for the month calculate the weights form
the portfolio and calculate the daily
return for our portfolio and for our
strategy all right so let's
start first you want to create the
returns data
frame would be we calculate log returns
so from new data frame we'll select the
adjusted Clause column take a log and
then the difference that would give
us the
returns data frame
awesome after we have the returns we'll
create
portfolio DF which would be an
empty data
frame and then we will Loop over so for
start date in
fixed dates. keys so we are going to
Loop over our dictionaries for start
date let's so for each date we are going
to first get the end date so the end
date would be should be the end of the
month right we're investing for one
month and then we rebalancing so at the
beginning of uh November 2017 we want to
select the returns from this return data
frame we want to select the returns for
the next month right so the end date
would be the end of November
2017 that will be P to date time start
date
Plus
pandas date
offsets actually I think here we'll use
offsets and then
month
end and we can call the string F time
method so we have
the right format and we can print that
now actually we can print both the start
date and we can
print the end
date for each month we have the start of
the month and the end of the month and
now the next step is to get the columns
for the month to do that we can just say
the following so columns would be equal
to fixed dates and we are just going to
select the star
date and those are going to be our
columns right so those are going to be
the stocks for each month that uh we are
going to form portfolio portfolios with
after we have the start date and date
and the stocks for the given month now
we want to calculate the weights but to
calculate the weights we need to do the
optimization and as we already know to
find the optimized weights we need a
onee data prior to the start date and it
has to be daily so for that data we'll
use the new data frame that we've just
downloaded which contains the prices and
pretty much what do what do we want so
to calculate the weights for all stocks
at the beginning of November 2017 so for
all those stocks we would have to input
the prices for one year prior of those
stocks into this function which will
calculate the weights and then we'll
have the weights for uh for the first
month so for the November 2017 in this
case we would have to create an
optimization data frame first we have an
optimization optimization start
date and it would be pandas to date
time
start date it would be the given start
date 1st of November 2017 minus Panda's
date off
set and we will supply
months minus 12 months exactly so
exactly 12 months ago would be the
optimization start
date
and we
will create an optimization end date as
well so the end date would be
actually again start dat minus however
one date and now we can print to
visualize everything we here so far so
we have the start
date we
have we have the start date then we have
the end date then we have the stocks
that would be included in a given month
then we have the optimization start date
and optimization end
date
date of
set my bad so date of
set and now for this month so for 2017
from 1st of uh November until the thir
30th of November that would be the
stocks in our portfolio and we'll have
an optimization so to calculate the
weights for those stocks we have an
optimization data frame which would be
for exactly one year prior to the
starting date so from uh 1st of November
2016 up to 31st of October
2017 and now the next step is to
calculate the weights for the weights we
use we are going to use that was my
point one so we're going to use our
optimize weight
function
and and here we have to supply the
prices of the optimized weight and the
lower bound right the prices would be
actually an optimization data frame this
optimization data frame we can use the
new data frame which contains prices
right and we can select the following
dates from the optimization start date
to optimization and date then we will
select the adjusted close and we want
only the columns that we are going to
use for a portfolio for this month and
that would be pretty much our
optimization dat frame so in this case
yeah when I run it so that's that
because in the for Loop the the last
values for the start and end date would
be the last values based on the last
value of the fixed date key so it it's
fter out from uh 3rd of October 2022 up
to 29th of September 2023 that's around
almost one year but what we are going to
do for the sake of Simplicity because
our first start date is 200 yeah
2017 1st of November we are going to
select the following date
2016 1st of
November until 2017
30 to
October and this is going to be our
optimization data frame to calculate the
weights we are going to supply that up
here as well we have to supply the lower
bound that for each stock what would be
the lower bound the upper bound we know
it's
10% maybe we want to make it this one
dynamic as well but for now let's keep
it 10% but the lower bound we want to be
half of an equally weighted portfolio so
a equally weighted portfolio is going to
have weights which are pretty
much equal to one divided by the number
of Assets in the portfolio so the number
of columns in this case we can
use we can so we would have 10 columns
so 10 assets for a given month so the
equally weighted portfolio would have
10% for each stock half of that that
would be the number of stocks multiplied
by two I mean one divided by the number
of stocks multiplied by two and that
would be 0. uh
0.05 and now we can wrap that around in
a round function so we are always sure
we have around weight and now we can run
it to optimize our weights however I
think that up
here our columns are actually not the
right columns because we would have to
select
the first optimization date so that
would be
11 this is the list of our
columns and our optimization data frame
will be the following and now we can
input it here and check out the
weights this now
looks quite
interesting
first let's take a look at the lower
bound so the lower bount is
0.01 if we
apply it will be 0.012 okay maybe we can
use a rounding of three instead of
two okay now this looks better those
will be the weights of our port
portfolio in November
2017 as you can see for stocks they have
a weight of 0.01 so 1.2% of our total
portfolio and then we have this stock
which has 10% of our portfolio this one
has seven this one has
6.8%
5.9 3% 4% 4% that's what we are going to
do at the beginning of each month we are
going to optimize and find the weights
for our stocks for for that month okay
now we we can Implement that into our
optimization so up here we are going to
provide the weights and Next Step would
be to create the returns date frame but
actually before that I think we have we
can turn that into a data frame so we
can say the following weight equals to
pandas data frame frame and then weights
and index is uh Panda series and now we
have the weights as a data
frame and we can now potentially use
that with the returns data frame to
multiply the way to Fe stock for the
given month by the return for that stock
for every day and this way we'll be able
to calculate the portfolio return for
each day okay next step would be to
create a temporary datea frame which
would be equal to returns data
frame and here we'll use the start
date up to the end date we are going to
filter the beginning of month so that
would be
2017 first until
2017 13th that will be our temporary
data frame let's see what we have
here yeah so we pretty much selected the
stocks and the the returns of the stocks
for the given month the selected stocks
and now what we would like to do is just
merge with the weights data frame to get
the stock return for each day and the
weight for that day we can do the
following first stock we are going to
stock and then we're going to say to
frame to frame
return now we have for each day all the
stocks and then the return column and
now we want to reset the
index we are going to reset the date
index
and
next step is to
merge with the
weights are looking something like that
we can
say
stock to frame
weight and we can remove we have now a
multi index up here so level zero level
one so we want to remove the
zero we can say reset
index level zero drop equals to true
because we want to just drop it
directly
and we are going to merge those two left
by index so left index true right index
true as
well and we'll get something which looks
like that the
next step would be
to reset the
index and set a new
multi-index date
and I think this one doesn't have a name
right now so it would be just called
index and now we have almost what we
want so we can say
unstack and then
stock and now we have the data frame
with the return for the given date and
the weight of the stock for the whole
month of our stock and we can call this
our temp dat
frame the temp dat frame was initially
the start
date to the end
date we can grab that put it up over
here and
[Music]
now we can grab this part as
well put it over
here and let's take a look
again now we can just simply use a
vectorized operation we can multiply the
return column by the weight column
and then we can get the waited return
for each stock for every day of the
given month and let's do that but before
maybe we would like to fix the index so
the index to be the index names actually
so date and thicker to keep things
tidy
names and now now we would like to
calculate the
weighted return for each stock which
would be
just the return return
column multiplied by the weight
column and now we have the weighted
return for each day for each stock and
the next step would be just to calculate
the daily the sum of the daily weighted
return which would be our portfolio
return for the given day and we can do
that by saying the following Group by
level one or date level zero or date
whatever
you prefer so awaited return do
sum that will be the portfolio return
for every day and then we can just say
to
frame and and call it strategy
return and that will be our strategy
return for the for the selected month
obviously we are looping over each month
and we are doing the the operations for
every month we can assign that to the
temp
DF
and move it over
here and the next operation would be
just to you
know concut this to the portfolio data
frame so portfolio data frame will be to
pandas concut portfolio data frame with
temporary date frame axis equal to zero
or the default axis and that should be
it guys we have our so we Loop over each
month we select the optimization dat
frame we are doing the optimization
calculating the weights then we are
merging the weights with the returns of
those stocks for the given month and
we're uh calculating the waited return
for each day for our portfolio which is
our strategy return for every day let's
run that and see if it's going to work
out okay so we
have an error which is
return okay so I found how to overcome
the error we'll just Implement and try
and accept cloud
so
[Music]
try
and we'll try to run that
except exception s
e and we'll just print the exception as
well I was digging through the code and
I figured out guys that we have forgot a
really important part of it and up here
we don't specify the optimization data
frame we would have to add that
the optimization data frame was pretty
much our new data frame where we select
the optimization start date and the
optimization end
date and then we select the adjusted
close and the columns for the given
month and with that I think now the code
the optimization part should be pretty
much fixed and we have something so
please check your objective constraint
or use different
so so status invasible okay yeah so uh
this is actually happening from time to
time and pretty much the solver is not
able to optimize the max Sharpie ratio
weights and instead it's failing if we
visualize the portfolio returns you can
see those periods where there is no data
so pretty much the so over has not
optimized the portfolio we didn't have
any weights and we end up with no
investment for those months a work
around would be actually to do the
following I've really spent some time on
that part and unfortunately there is no
easy solution for this uh optimization
failing for the max sharp ratio the only
workaround I figure out is to implement
the following whenever the optimization
fails and we don't have the max Sharpie
ratio weights we will use equal weights
for our portfolio as simple as that
we'll do the following so we'll try to
calculate the weights and
then if this doesn't work out we'll do
accept and then we'll print that
Max sharp
optimization failed
for
start
date
continuing with equal
weights and let's see if this is the
issue if we run that now it should print
yeah exactly so for those months the max
Sharpie ratio optimization failed and we
have to continue with equal weights so
how do we do that we'll do that the
following way we'll create a new
variable which is
success and it will be equal to false
however if the weights have been
optimized it will be equal to
true all right and then we can just do
the following so if
success is
false our
weights would be pretty much we would
create a pandas data frame with our
weight so pandas data frame but let me
take this out of here let's put it down
here we'll create a pandas data frame
and then we
want equal weights so we can just use
this part right here we want equal
weights so that would be the equal
weight right one weight but we want it
for for the number of stocks in our
portfolio so it will be for I in range L
optimization DF do
columns
yeah that would be our equal weights
and then we have to supply the index and
the index would be just the
columns is a list so columns to
list
and the
columns would be a pandas
series zero and this would give us a
data frame containing the stocks for the
given month with uh their weight
assigned as an equal uh equal weight and
we can just transpose
that and have it like that so this would
be our equal weights data
frame
if our optimization
fails and we'll have only equal weights
whenever the optimization fails and
after implementing that
so yeah pretty much you can Implement a
print for print statements throughout
the code to double check if uh we work
correctly but I can assure you that it's
working correctly and now if you want to
visualize the returns just do a simple
plot you see that we have the returns
throughout the whole time frame and with
that pretty much guys we are ready with
our strategy portfolio building we may
want to apply to drop duplicates up here
if we have any duplicates I think we
don't but just in
case and yeah with that guys we are
ready for the next step and in The Next
Step we're going to visualize the
returns of our portfolio and compare it
to a benchmark which in this case would
be the S&P 500 Index itself it will be
really interesting to see the results of
all that hard work so far so let's move
to that
part and to compare our portfolio to the
S&P 500 first thing would be to just
download the returns for S&P 500 so we
can say for so spy and we have uh we
download
the from wi Finance
stickers AR tier would be spy the ATF on
S&P 500 the start date we can just
Supply like
2015 1st of January and the end date we
can supply daytime date
today and now we
would pretty much create a new object
let's call it spycor red so spy return
and here will just take the log return
of
spy and just
close then
difference then drop an
name
rename and yeah
first let's check
spirate
before okay so this is the log return of
spy for each day and now I'll would just
like to rename the adjusted close to
Benchmark return or spy Buy and Hold
would be adjusted close
to
spy Buy and
Hold AIS equ
one and then we can use the portfolio
data
frame to merge the Spy return to the
port for dat FR so left index would be
true right index would be
true by the 4 is an inner joint so we
don't have to worry
about uh okay so we'll just you know
we'll just rerun
this sell and then we'll run rerun this
one and now we have the strategy return
and the Spy Buy and Hold return for the
same dates and we can move to the next
step where we would like to you know
calculate the cumulative return for both
the S&P 500 and for our strategy and
plot them to compare them in time we'll
do the following M lip style. use ggplot
I think we've done that previously but
just in case and now we want to
calculate the portfolio cumulative
return cumulative
return and that would be from npy
expanding window so NY
XP
log from portfolio data frame and then
after that we call the
and this should
calculate the cumulate is starting from
one but we have to say minus
one and now we would have the cumulative
return for our strategy and the S&P 500
itself now what we may want to do do is
just to select for example that we want
the portfolio return up to a given point
let's say we want it up to 29th of uh
September so we just say up to 0.9 20
29 and then we can plot that we can say
fix
size 16x 6 and
and and that's uh pretty much uh that's
our comparison guys we can add a title
so p. title
unsupervised learning trading
strategy returns over time as well we
may want to PTY
label return return
and maybe we would like to fix a little
bit the axis up here to be in
percentages so we can call the following
GCA do ya
axis set
major
formatter and here we can supply a
formatter like there is a format from
MTI but I think we have
to first sent format
there I think we have to import it up
here so we have to import from
modb forat B Li
thicker same thck uh so import map yeah
as MTI and this would do
it uh Y
axis set major
format and
that is pretty much our strategy guys up
here we have selected the 150 most
liquid stocks for each month we have
calculated 18 different features on each
stock then we used a c's clustering
algorithm to assign a cluster for every
stock we supplied our custom sent we
initialized our sent with a custom array
and then for each month we optimized the
portfolio to have the maximum Sharpie
portfolio weights for every new month
and form this strategy using S&P 500
stocks and now we compare to the return
of the S&P 500 nevertheless this is not
a financial advice you shouldn't use
that anyway if you come up here and just
change the logic for uh selecting the
stocks from third cluster to zero uh to
Cluster zero everything will be changed
on the spot and you see that the results
would change dramatically as well that's
just example of how we can Implement
machine learning into trading strategies
and forming portfolios Etc so that's
pretty much it for this strategy and
into the next one we're going to form
portfolios using Twitter sentiment data
I'm looking forward to that and let's
move to the second
project in the second project we are
going to build a Twitter sentiment
investing strategy for this project we
are going to load a data set which will
be available for you to download from
the description of the video there is a
link where you can download the data set
used in this project and in the third
project as well the notebook or all
three projects would be available on
that link too so we would be loading
this data set containing Twitter
sentiment data on stocks from NASDAQ 100
this strategy would be focused on NASDAQ
100 stocks and we are using Twitter
sentiment data the idea here is that I
would like to to it will be a smaller
project than the first one but I would
like to show you how we can create a
derivative feature from the Twitter
sentiment data to create potential value
for our investments first we'll start by
importing the
packages those are the packages we're
going to use panda snai m clip datetime
wi finance and the operational system
package we import daytime is DT that's
the I think we're going to change and
again we are going to use ggplot as our
mpot lip style first let's define our
data folder so this would be the path to
the sentiment data file you're going to
download so it would be a CSV file this
is my folder which contains the data and
you would have to assign the path to
your folder up here let's load the data
so
sentiment data frame would be uh pandas
read
CSV and here we have to supply the puff
os. puff.
jooin data folder and the file name so
the file name is sentiment data.csv
and let's run that and see what we have
here that is the the sentiment data we
have we got the the date the symbol and
the corresponding Twitter posts Twitter
comments Twitter likes Twitter
Impressions and the Twitter sentiment
uh the Twitter sentiment is calculated
uh by the methodology used by the data
provider we just use it as it is here
the first thing we want to fix is the
date we want the date column to be date
time so pandas to date
time and next step is
to set the indexes again we are going to
work with the multi-index in two levels
so sentiment dat data frame set
index this is going to be the date and
the
symbol
date and
symbol so far so good now I would like
to calculate a Quant feature out of this
data and it would be called actually I'm
interested in the engage the Twitter
engage each stock here yes not only just
the raw sentiment or the RO Impressions
likes and comments but I'm interested in
the engagement that people have on the
posts on Twitter for this company
because we know that there are a lot of
bots on Twitter and they are messing up
the data skewing the data on some post
or some symbols and actually I would
like to have engagement ratio which may
be more
informative than having just the live
likes or the comments or the sentiment
on its own and this engagement ratio
will be pretty much the Twitter comments
divided by the Twitter likes if a given
company has a lot of likes but no
comments we know that this is Bots
activity but if there are quite some a
lot of comments and a lot of likes as
well and actually the comments are as
much as the likes are even more we know
that people are engaged on this stock
let's calculate the engagement ratio
engagement ratio and this engagement
ratio will be pretty much Twitter
comments divided by Twitter likes so how
much are the
comments compared to the
likes
and that's our engagement ratio for we
have this engagement ratio for each
stock for every day and now we may just
want to filter out the data frame to to
contain only stocks that have for
example more than u a given amount of
likes so let's say we want stocks that
have more than 20 likes for a given day
and more than 10 comments on a given day
because otherwise it's just random
noise so Twitter
likes we would like to have more than 20
likes
and You' like stock to have more than 10
columns to be kept into our investment
universe and with that we are pretty
much ready with the first step we are
following pretty much the similar logic
to the previous project however here
we're going to create an equally
weighted portfolio we are not going to
implement the efficient Frontier
optimization ation every month we would
decide an investment Universe of top
five stocks and just invest into them
and now after we have uh calculated the
engagement ratio now we want to pretty
much calculate the average engagement
ratio for each stock for every month and
we can do that the following way so we
the reset the symbol index the symbol
part of the index we reset symbol and
then we'll Group
by we'll group byy for every
month and every stock we'll Group by on
the monthly level and the symbol level
and then we are going to maybe we can
put that into
brackets then we are going to select the
engagement ratio
column and calculate that the average
engagement ratio for the whole month
pretty
much and now we can assign that to uh
new variable new data frame called
aggregated
DF and now we can calculate the
cross-sectionally the rank for each
month of all the stocks based on this
engagement ratio how do we do that we
say a new column rank we are going to
group by level zero or date so we are
grouping by each month because already
we have uh aggregated to the monthly
level right so we group up group on each
month and then we select the engagement
ratio and then we are doing the
following so on the next row we're going
to say transform
Lambda but maybe we can put that into
brackets and move that on the next row
so Lambda X and here we'll just say x.
rank
ascending equals to
false and this would create a new column
called rank cross-sectionally for each
month based on the engagement ratio and
the stocks with the highest engagement
ratio would have the highest rank and we
can obviously see that already so now we
want to pretty much select for each
month the top five stocks for each month
based on this Rank and grab them to use
similarly to what we did in the previous
project grab the start date and the
stocks that we want to include in the
next month and then calculate the
returns but this time in an equally
weighted fashion so let's do that I'll
cut those
celles and yeah now we'll just select
the top five stocks for each
month so we'll do the
following aggregated data frame rank
where is below six and now we have the
stocks with the highest engagement ratio
for each month we can assign that to
filtered DF data
frame
and after we have the filter DF data
frame we can just reset the symbols part
of the index so reset index level equals
to one and
then we
just fix the index again the same way we
did last time so we'll just add one day
to your index so plus day time uh
Panda's date of set one day let's see
what this would give us now we have the
beginning of the next month and the
stocks we want to invest in for the next
month so those five stocks for each
month and yeah pretty much next step is
to uh reset the index and set again the
multi
index we'll set the multi index again
date
symbol and
visualize top 20 rows so far so good now
for for the beginning of each new month
we have the top five stocks by
engagement ratio and now we would like
to create the fixed dates object like we
did in the first project from dates
would be good to filter data frame index
get level values
date and here yeah unique and to list so
we make a
list and fixed dates would be again a
dictionary empty
dictionary for D
dates pretty much we are following the
exact same logic we did in the previous
projects so it's quite straightforward I
hope this stuff will guys however uh
yeah in this project we are not doing
the efficient front here optimization
just rather use a weekly weighted
portfolio the idea here is to show you
how we can extract value from different
uh data
sets and yeah as you can see now for
each new month we have the list of five
stocks we are going to invest in and the
next step would be to download the fresh
prices to do that we can first create
our stocks list it would be equal to
sentiment data frame do index
get level values
symbol and
again unique to
list this is our stock list and we can
create a new data frame pric DF where we
are going to
download again from yaho
final our start date we can use as you
you can see the we can use just the 1st
of January
2021 to be sure we have enough
prices and the end date would be
2023 1st of
March so
2023 1 of
March awesome after we have our our list
of stocks for each month and the prices
we can move to the next step where we
are going to calculate the portfolio
returns following similar logic to what
we did in the last section so from
prices
DF we can select the adjusted close
column and
calculate the log returns for each stock
and yeah pretty much call that returns
date frame so after and we can drop the
na values in the
end after we have the returns we can now
create portfolio data frame which is
just an empty data
frame and for start
date in fixed dates.
Keys print start date just to visualize
what we have so far so for each for each
month we have the start date and now we
want the end
date for our
portfolio so end date would be pandas to
datetime start date plus
pandas
offsets month
end which will
give us
the which should give
us which should give us the end date of
the same
month uh okay pretty
much we have that however we would have
to add the string F time method in the
end like that that's pretty awesome so
what was the next step The Next Step was
to select the columns or for the given
month that will be the stocks we are
going to invest for that month and these
will be fixed
dates start
date so for each month the stocks we
have to invest for that month and now we
can create our temp data frame
where we would be calculating the
equally weighted return for our
portfolio for every day this would be
returns date frame here we'll save from
start date to the end date and then for
the selected columns we're going to
calculate the mean the
average by columns so the average daily
return and we call that in the end we
say to frame and then portfolio return
portfolio return next step would be just
for each month to
concut this portfolio
return and with that we have calculated
the equally weighted portfolio return
for every month for those stocks we have
selected using our methodology about
aggregated uh mon monthly
average engagement ratio for every stock
and then ranked
cross-sectionally and now we are ready
to pretty much visualize the return the
cumulative return of our portfolio and
compare it for example to a benchmark
like NASDAQ right those stocks are
constituents of NASDAQ so we may want to
compare it to the NASDAQ indexes a
benchmark again guys I've said it in the
beginning of the tutorial and the course
we're using stock lists which are not
survivorship bias free and that is
really important and most probably
skewing the results upwards so you
should never use you should always use
survival ship bias free stock list when
you're researching strategies so now
what do we want we want to just download
the
prices for the NASDAQ or the NASDAQ ETF
which is QQQ so we would use start date
to be 2021 1st of January and the end
date would be pretty much the same as
for our portfolio so first of
March and now we can calculate the
NASDAQ return so
QQQ return that would
be log
from the adjusted
close
differen and we may want to rename it to
Mazda
return and with that we're ready to
merge
together the can return to
[Music]
our portfolio date frame so
we merge by
index by theault the merge is always
using uh in our joint so we are not
obliged to specify
that or maybe we
are no we are
not
and now we have the portfolio return for
every day and the NASDAQ return for
every day and the next step would be to
just visualize so we can say the
following
portfolios
cumulative return will be equal to uh
we'll calculate that in a n expanding
window where we take uh
log from the return of both portfolios
and then
we apply the cumulative some over the
whole expanding window so for for each
new uh each new addition We Run The
accumulator some in the end we have to
substract one and that's pretty much
ready for plotting so we create a plot
with a fix size equal to 16 and six and
we can set a
title like Twitter
engagement ratio Str
return over time as
well P
GCA Y axis set major format that would
set the the y- axis to be a
percentage so we'll use the percent
format as well we give a name to the Y
uh label
and we
just show
and that's pretty much our second
project guys about the Twitter sentiment
investing strategy with monthly
rebalancing of an equally weighted
portfolio our uh stock selection
criteria is based on the engagement
ratio which we calculators the Twitter
comments divided by the Twitter likes
for each stock and we select the top
stocks which had the highest average
engagement ratio for every month if you
want to change the selection criteria
for example if you want to select the
stocks which have on average the most
likes for every month you just we can
just simply do that so cop this com put
it up here then put it up
here and now we have the new we have
pretty much the ranking done by average
T likes through throughout the month and
if we run the symbols down the sales
down
below it will be redone using the
likes
and yeah as you can see when we use the
likes our strategy
underperforms however if you use the
comments maybe we can try with the
comments to see what what would be the
results with the
coms similar results similar results
however a little bit um higher
performance so the idea here is to show
you that if we have alternative data we
may need to implement some calculations
to get a derivative features which then
may be valuable for our research and for
our strategies that is the main idea
here and if
we return the engagement
ratio let run the whole thing we are
able to see the difference in the
results obviously the engagement ratio
by using the engagement ratio we have
some we've created a little bit of value
above the NASDAQ itself and that is
pretty much it about the second project
and we are able to now move to the third
project where we are going to create
intraday trading strategy on a simulated
one asset data using a gar model so a
model to predict the one day ahead
volatility and it will be a really
interesting one so I'm really excited to
move to the third project and let's get
into
it in the third project we are creating
an intraday strategy using gar model
we're going to use simulated daily data
and simulated intraday 5 minute data on
a single asset and we are going to
create two signals on two different time
frames on the daily level and on the
intraday level so on The Daily level our
signal would be driven by the gar model
volatility prediction we are going to
fit in a rolling window for every day a
gar model and predict the volatility for
the next day and from that we're going
to calculate the prediction premum
premium and derive our daily signal out
of that on the intraday level we are
going to calculate technical indicators
and create a signal following a intraday
price action pattern and merge with the
daily signal and calculate our final
signal intraday only for those days
where simultaneously we have the
intraday and the daily signal and
whenever we have the the intraday signal
we are going either into a long or into
a short position and we're holding until
the end of the day and that's pretty
much the strategy guys let's start by
first loading the data we are going to
use so the data again it will be
available for you to download from the
link down in the video description first
we start by importing all the packages
we'll be using for this project they are
MP lip Arc we'll use the arc project for
the gar model then uh Panda snai and the
operation system package again our uh
data
folder you have to provide the path to
your data folder and we can start by
loading the data so daily uh data frame
would be pandas read
CSV all spot
join and then the daily date frame which
is
simulated daily data.
CSV and this should be our daily data
here we would have to fix the date we
use pandas to
daytime
and we Supply the
date as well then we are going to set
the index for to the Daily date frame to
be the
date pretty much standard stuff and our
I have already calculated the log return
but to repeat that I'll just calculate
the log return which would be n
log from the adjusted close and then we
just do the dot difference method and so
far so good that's our daily data and
our intraday data would be intraday 5
minutes
DF again we are going to load it using
pandas stre CSV so p.
join and the name of the file is
simulated 5 minutes data.
CS we can commment out this
code this one as well and here first
first step we need to fix the daytime
column to be date time so pandas to date
time that's the first
step then we want to assign it as an
index and the next step would be to
calculate this date column so we can
just redo that real quick or we
just cast it to data we already have it
so we'll cast it to daytime but if
you're wondering what it is it's just
selecting the index and then
date which which would give us the date
column and with that we are pretty much
ready with loading our daily and
intraday 5 minute data and we're ready
to move to the second step so in this
step we are going to define a function
which would fit a gar model and predict
the volatility for one day ahead in a
rolling window we'll use a six months
rolling window for that but the
specification here is that whenever you
fit a gar model you need to supply the
auto regressive and moving moving
average orders you need to actually find
those orders and to do that I've used a
Brute Force approach where I fit 16
models with a combination for the outo
aggressive and moving a average orders
from one to four and combinations
between them so I fit 16 models then
I've extracted the mean square error and
the beian information Criterion and
pretty much I chose the best model to be
the one who is minimizing the beian
information Criterion so I found that
the best G model on this data is having
Auto regressive order of one and moving
average order of three so P = to 1 and Q
= to 3 so that's a really important um
clarification first you start by
calculating on The Daily data frame the
variance or actually the rolling six
months
variance of the log
return that would be the
variance
and we may want to visualize
that this is the variance of our data
the variance of the log return of our
data through time and now we would
actually want to for the sake of
Simplicity I'll just filter out the date
to be be from 2020
onwards and now I'm going to create a
predict volatility function so we are
going to predict the
volatility for every day so so far we
have the Vance pretty much the
volatility is predicting the Vance with
a G model when you fit a g model You can
predict the variance or the uh the mean
of the series we're going to predict the
variance of our asset for every day and
we would have to do that in a rolling
window so first we create the best model
which would be where you going to use
the arc
model and here we have to supply Y which
will be our X or the series then p is
the order the regressive order the
moving average order Q so those values
we have to find with the Brute Force
approach as I did I mean fitting 16 or
25 models collecting the metric the mean
squar error the be information Criterion
after you have run the model and
choosing the one which is minimizing the
for example the bean information
criteria that's the best model so after
we have supplied arguments to the arc
model next we are going to fit the model
here we would say the update frequency
to be every five steps and this position
to be off and this is our best model and
now we can forecast right VAR forecast
so from the best model we are going to
forecast Horizon equals to 1 so for one
day ahead our data is daily so for one
day ahead and then after the forecast is
done for next day we have two columns or
two vales the mean or the Vance so we
choose the Vance and and we're going to
choose the last value so last row of the
First Column we may want to print the
date so x. index last date the one we
are going to forecast for then we'll
just return the VAR forecast and this is
our prediction function guys now we'll
just say the following
predictions and our predictions are
going to
be based on the log return
we're going
to apply a function in a rolling window
of 180 days the same way as we did for
the Varan 180 days and here we say
Lambda x equal to predict volatility
X and we can now pretty much run
that okay yeah my bad there is no do up
here
what is the
problem okay I think yeah it's
iock here and this will now just run in
a rolling window fit the best G model we
know that the best G model for our data
is auto regressive order of one moving
average order of three and yeah we just
have to wait for this thing to run
and predict the
volatility for the whole data set after
we are done with that we will move to
the next uh step where we are going to
calculate the prediction premium and
form a daily signal out of it okay so
the model is done fitting and predicting
the Vance and we can now take a look we
have the V and the predictions actually
if you look closer then the Val are
pretty close and similar actually we may
want to visualize them if you're
interested guys let's see what we have
here so we have the Vance and the
predictions and yeah maybe we can just
plot them so the Vance is more stable
than the predictions and as you can see
the predictions are exploding here or
there but we may deal with that if we
apply a rolling average or a CA filter
model on the predictions they will
smooth them out
considerably however for the sake of
this strategy and this course I'm not
going to implement that but usually you
may think about it you know like signal
reduction techniques okay so the next
step we are going to calculate feature
called prediction premium and after we
have the prediction premium we'll
calculate the six months rolling
standard deviation of that uh prediction
premium and from there we'll be able to
calculate and create our daily signal
the prediction premium would be a very
simple formula it would be equal to
predictions
minus so from the predictions we are
going to substract the Varan and then
we're going to scale the whole thing by
the varas itself it's a simple
formula then we're going to calculate
the premium standard
deviation premium standard
deviation which would be just a rolling
6 months standard
deviation and let's run that and see
what we have now we have the prediction
premium let's visualize it real
quick so this is the prediction premium
and we have the standard deviation of
this prediction premium awesome from now
on we can create our daily signal right
so our signal daily will be the
following our daily signal will
calculate by doing apply Lambda over
each roll we have one if prediction
premium is higher than the premium
standard deviation multiplied by 1.5 so
1.5 if the prediction premium is higher
than 1.5 standard deviations then we
have long signal or one else we would
have minus one if the prediction premium
is smaller than minus 1.5 standard
deviations and here we have to say the
following else MP
n and
then we'll do
that for axis equal to one we're doing
that for each row right let's see what
this would give us this would create
this signal daily column so whenever you
know the prediction premium is higher
than 1.5 standard deviations or lower
than 1.5 standard deviations we get the
signal we may want to explore that a
little
bit equals to
one we have quite some signals for long
but actually you know what we may do the
following we may just plot a histogram
instead of uh you know obing the we want
to understand how much short and how
much long signals we have so kind
histogram and then p.
show this would create histogram and
we'll be able to understand how
many okay so what is the
problem
funny okay so now we can see that we
have around 50 long signals and then
around 35 short signals and yeah with
that we are ready with our daily signal
guys and we can move to the intraday
part of the strategy and here we are
going to merge our daily data with the
intraday data based on the based on the
column on the date column have created
actually to do that we need to shift the
daily data one day ahead right because
at the end of the 29th for example we
have the daily data but we'll be using
it on the 30th so we need to do the
following up here we need to say signal
daily will be
just
shifted one day
forward that's pretty much what we have
to to say and we can move to forming the
final data frame here we can use our
intraday data frame we're going to reset
the index and then we're going to merge
so do
merge actually we may move that on the
next row so we are going to merge with
the daily date
frame and actually only with signal
column because we are not interested in
the other daily columns we interested
only in the signal column we're going to
reset the index on The Daily data frame
as well and here we'll be using the left
on so left on date left on this this
column and right on date as well or on
the index column pretty much this one
after the reset it will be available as
a
column
and that's pretty much our join now we
have the five uh five minute intraday
data right and we have the daily signal
derived by the gar volatility prediction
now we may just want to set the index to
be the DAT time again and that's pretty
much our final data
frame we can call it final data
frame
comment that
out okay so now we want to drop those
two columns we don't need the those two
date columns so we'll say the
following final DF do
drop and yeah we'll drop date and
date and we are ready now to calculate
all the technical indicators potentially
we can use for this strategy to do that
we we will need the pandas ta package
which I forgot to import so we are going
to import the pandas ta
package and the first indicator I would
like to calculate is the RSI indicator
from Pand ta we are going to use the RSI
my to and we'll just apply the close
price and the
length would be 20 next one is uh the
Ballinger bands I would like to
calculate so b or lower
band
first here it's B bands again it takes
the close price as an argument however
the B bands are returning five columns
instead of one we have to specify that
we want the First Column to be returned
so iock all the rows and the First
Column that would be our lower band and
for our upper band it would be the third
column lower middle
[Music]
upper those are going to be Ballinger
band lower upper band and now I would
like to have potentially to use the ls
of the lower and over band but let's
continue with d and for after we have
calculated the indicators we can just
run that part check out the
indicators and now we can move on to
calculate the intraday signal so signal
intraday would be the followings so we
have a intraday signal whenever the RSI
is above 70 and the close price closes
above the upper Ballinger band so
whenever the RSI is above 70 and and the
price closes above the upper boringer
band we have a burst of momentum upwards
or downwards that's my strategy idea and
this would be our Buy Signal and the
sell would be when at RS SI is below 30
and simultaneously we have a close below
the lower bar this price action pattern
is a pure momentum pattern and we can
again uh calculate using the applied
Lambda function so one if RSI is above
70 and if the close
price is above the upper band else we
would like minus one if the opposite
pretty
much
right R side below 30 and close below
the lower band else we would like to
have MP n if those conditions are not
met and the axis will be equal to one we
can run that and see what we
call we have a small Arrow up
here
why okay so there's something wrong with
our
data we can call the info
and everything is
float what is the problem here
guys
I found the error guys I have forgot to
add the X up here for both the upper and
the lower bound and that
was doing the error it's going to
calculate the intraday strategy signal
as well now and
with that we are actually pretty much
ready with our intraday signal and our
daily signal and we can move on now to
generating our entry points and our
final signal the final signal that we
are going to use to calculate our daily
returns from to do that we are going to
do the following so final DF return
signal or return sign that will be the
of our return and actually the direction
of the position it would be the
following we would have a short position
whenever the daily signal is one so the
prediction premium is above one standard
1.5 standard deviations High prediction
premium let me grab that signal daily so
whenever the signal daily is equal to
one and the signal
intraday is equal to one as well the
intraday situation is that the price is
super overextended our RSI above 70 and
simultaneously the close is above the
upper Binger band so I assume a mean
reversion and on the day we know that
the prediction premium the volatility is
above the rolling standard deviation or
1.5 1.5 rolling standard deviations
whenever we have those conditions met we
are going into a short position else
we're going into a long position
whenever we have the opposite so both
the daily signal and the intraday signal
are minus one and else we have MP
none and the axis would be equal to one
as well and this would be our intraday
signal to get into a long or a short
position invalid syntax
okay I forgot the com up
here that's
enough okay I'm not sure guys what's the
problem here
but all right I think I had forgotten
this something you know okay now we have
the intraday signal for each position my
idea here is the following so whenever
intraday whenever in the in a given day
we have this signal the first trigger of
that position we are going into a
position and we'll be holding for the
whole day so the first time it can be in
10:00 but we can have another signal in
the same day uh at 5:00 we don't care
about the second one we are going into
full position position on the first one
and we are going to hold for the whole
day in this return sign column whenever
we have the first occurrence of the
signal what do we want to do we want to
forward feel until the end of the day
the same position sign to do that we can
use the following trick return sign
would be first let's explore what we
have I'm sorry let's explore what we
have so far so the return sign is our
intraday
final
signal uh
wow okay so this one should be
one all right so whenever we have to go
into a long position we have long signal
right here the return sign we can
observe that this happened at uh in 2021
18th of October at 605 then we had
another signal on the 23rd of October
then on the 28th on the 29th etc etc so
in some days we may have only one signal
but in some days we may have two or more
we don't care about the second or the
third signal we care only about the
first one so at this point in time we
had the signal and on the next bar so on
the next 5 minutes on the open price we
are going to go into a position and we
want to hold it until the end of the day
at the end of the day we close the
position an easy way to calculate the
strategy return would be to use just the
vectorizer return right so we are going
to forward f for every 5 minutes after
the entry time we're going to forward f
with the same sign the return sign
column how do we do that final DF do
group by pandas grouper we are going to
group for every day we are going to
group on a daily basis we are going to
select the return sign and now we'll use
the transform
method and because we have supplied one
or MP9 we are able to use a transform
method and do Lambda X forward F and
this would now forward F this value
until the end of the day for every day
where we have a Val it will be done by
the first occurrence of the Val after we
run that we can now select where the
return is equal to one where we have the
entry signal and as you can see now we
have the first signal at 605 6010 615
Etc ET until the end of the day we can
now calculate the 5 minutes returns
shift them backwards with one row for
every day and multiply the return sign
column by the signal intraday let's do
that right now that would be The
Following
return percent change and we would like
to get the forward return right so
forward
return and this would be equal to our
return column shifted we don't need to
apply Group by daily here because our
data is continuous it's 5 minutes data
but it's uh from the beginning of the
day until the end of the day it is
continuous for every day including the
weekends and that's why we we can just
calculate the 5 minute return and then
shift it backwards with one row and our
final strategy return will be the
following so strategy return would be
equal to final data frame forward return
multiplied by the return
sign that would be our strategy return
but it will be on the 5 minute level so
we want to get the daily strategy return
so we'll calculate daily return data
frame and it would be the final data
frame do
groupby we're grouping on the daily
basis so for every day we're going to
group by
select the strategy return column and
just
Summit after we have the daily return
data frame we can move on to the final
step and we'll just calculate the
strategy cumulative
return that would be equal to expanding
window so numi expand
log and then cumulate
sum and we just substract one in the
end and we can plot the strategy
return we set title to be
intraday strategy
returns we fix the
yaxis uh values to be percentages again
so set major
format to be from
anti percent format
one the Y label we set it to return and
we're pretty much ready with
our graph and this is our strategy G as
you can see we have an inaday uh
strategy we may not trade for quite some
time up here we haven't trade for almost
six months but then we had some trades
and yeah whenever we have uh the match
of the daily signal and the intraday
signal
that's when we are going into trades and
we have the returns that's a strategy
using the machine learning model the gar
model to predict one day ahead
volatility in combination with simulated
intraday data and with that we're
finishing the third project and I really
really hope you've enjoyed it guys you
can find the data and the notebook Down
Below in the link if you're interested
to learn more how to back test Quant
strategies how to do algorithmic trading
there will be a link in the description
ion to my website where you can learn
more about algorithmic trading and quad
trading with python